you should do your own movie reviews oh
yeah I could I could you know give me a
movie out the review it now
and the matrix really which one though
first 9999 I give a matrix the first one
an A+ Wow for for what for first of all
that that you know I mean you've seen a
million movies do it but like that
camera setup they have where they have
that like you know when they go around
the body freeze and all that was the
first time they ever did that really
right so that's innovative in that Sun
and and and conceptually it's a high
concept movie I'm agile watching the
matrix for the first time oh yeah you
don't know what the [ __ ] is going on
right and and it's it's my it did the
delivery of that idea was almost perfect
and I'm glad Johnny Depp didn't do it
you know Johnny Depp was awesome
and Will Smith and Will Smith yeah and
and they went to you know beyond it was
the third one he was perfect for it he's
good in that movie because there's like
only he only says a few things
throughout Trinity but like that's the
whole movie like you dodge bullets but
the dead but the dojo but the dojo scene
the first one is so good though I mean
we've seen wirework but we had never
seen here's where you saw wirework for
the first time we're in an obvious way
which is in Crouching Tiger Hidden
Dragon and the matrix mm-hmm right you
saw it in ways that you know almost in a
fantasy way where you would float you
know and things like that that but it
works in the matrix or a world because
of the fact that it's not it's in your
head right but yeah I give matrix in a a
plus this the third one is a [ __ ] F
the second one is C they should only
make one which house key
well siblings do all three yeah yeah
their careers they have a series out on
Netflix called sense8 and it's supposed
to be pretty good I've never watched it
but I heard yeah but um the the only
movie they made aside from matrix that
was very good is V for Vendetta
it's a great movie yeah give you another
movie you Clara
I don't know see a movie George Miller's
Crossing you really want to get deep huh
newest gossip Miller's Crossing
is I give that it also an a-plus
soundtrack alone soundtrack is amazing
yeah and then John Tudor Rose
performance the best he's ever done I've
never seen of night of yeah right I I
doubt it's even compared Lee close to
compare night of John Turturro a night
of is I understand that he's been this
spectacular and everything he's done
it's true but Miller's Crossing it's
another level of weasel and cowardice
and and the diamonds up being humble and
then also very egotistical and and he
runs the gamut in this character and oh
my god it's he's a very bless a plus
just the soundtrack and that alone and
then Gabri is also you know the Coen
Brothers a lot of their movies are
cartoony in many ways like zooms and and
it's very innovative even if you see
there's something like Blood Simple they
do a lot of like artsy [ __ ] like bullets
and then like light shining through the
bullets you know holes and stuff like
that I mean you know they the Coen
brothers worked on evil that - what's
your favorite Coen Brothers movie ever
I think again because of the cartoons a
meanness of it is probably Raising
Arizona I love raising Arizona I mean
just this chase sequence alone of going
through the grocery store and the dogs
and all that stuff it's just so fun to
watch and in a lot of film school that's
what they show is that is that movie
that movie is very good and it's done
with such a low budget it's very like I
love it I think what sort of Holly
Hunter is great in it yeah yeah I should
do a movie thing